there's a line i improvised in the movie
looking at mcguire and holland and i
tell them
what
yeah i love them that was just me loving
them oh that was one of the best moments
in the movie no way i want to know
ladies and gentlemen andrew garfield has
come out to reveal that he is indeed the
werewolf i'm not the werewolf i promise
you i am he is finally finally talking
about spider-man no way home right here
from variety the headline is andrew
garfield finally spells about spider-man
return and future i came across this
because the quote was going around about
how he's talking about wanting to return
for spider-man no way home and then from
skimming this article we didn't really
read it because we wanted to react to it
with you guys on camera and see what he
has to say but from what i gathered
there's like six questions and there's
paragraphs for many of them so i'm like
oh man andrew garfield's talking in
depth about these [ __ ]
garden hose that's been kinked for
months on end of spring
i'm so excited to dive into this
absolutely guys if you go ahead and flip
that like button would really appreciate
it and also you know leave down in the
comments if you do want andrew garfield
to return i know you do anyhoo shall we
dive into this let's do it let's dive
into this first question first question
of the day starting simple why did you
say yes to no way home oh was it
expecting i won't do that [ __ ] right i
wasn't expecting to ever have a
conversation again about potentially
playing peter parker i felt very excited
to just be a fan again but i got this
call from amy pascal and kevin feige and
john watts with this idea can you
imagine getting that call all three and
they were all on a three-way call like
in their room because the pandemic like
high school it was immediately
undeniable it sounded incredibly fun
incredibly spiritual trippy and
thematically interesting on a base level
as a spider-man fan just the idea of
seeing three spider-men in the same
frame
was enough he's in the exact same
position
yeah the pitch was really really
enticing they said you played this
character in your way and what would you
want to explore if you had an
opportunity if you were dumped into this
other universe and faced with this
younger you and this older you how will
you respond oh how interesting so it's
like they explore options with him on
how we could approach this that's so
cool and you know that's a true
expectation like that's got to be a big
badge of respect of like you want my
input oh yeah especially to want the
input on something on this grand of a
caliber and how much stakes there are to
something like this that's so cool that
they gave him the option to like throw
some ideas of what you might want we
talked a lot about mentorship we talked
a lot about brotherhood oh man that's in
the film
what is it what it is to be the older
brother younger brother and the middle
brother there's also a thing of seeing
someone you love walking down a path
that you've already walked down and you
know it doesn't lead to the place where
you ultimately meant to go see that's so
good because part of the script that i
loved especially with the three
spider-man was that a lot of the way the
the relationships built and the plot
moved forward with them felt very
character-driven and it seems like a lot
of this was inspired further
conversation a hundred percent that
character is isolated in his emotional
experience and physical experience but
what happens when that aloneness gets
blasted open and you come to realize
that you've never been alone and there
are other brothers going through the
exact same thing that's a big spiritual
journey to go on man and then we just
milked out all the fun we possibly can
have yeah which it really does just show
in the movie and that speaks to i think
what is so effective about it because
just that attention to the emotional
resonance of it all is what's reaching
the most people and they clearly put the
most tlc into that which is very
inspiring on a hollywood scale
absolutely you and toby maguire really
did this this one yeah right they really
did this this wasn't a green screen set
up in your driveway and they have a
profound impact on tom hall and
spider-man we were shooting for two
weeks toby and i but i think we managed
to achieve something that is not just
showing up and going hi bye
that's that was so true like it's
something that felt so surreal and
uncanny but they're in the same room my
spider-man got to save his younger
brother's romantic relationship
potentially and to heal the most
traumatic moment of his own life through
doing it for his younger brother making
sure they didn't have the same fate
there's something cosmically beautiful
about that it meant getting a second
chance at saving gwen garfield's love
interest in the amazing spider-man
played by emma stone beautiful moment
brings a lot of people to tears it
brought me to tears each day every time
you know the spirit that zadea brings to
mj is so heartfelt and pure and loving
and emma brought that similar unique
spirit to gwen oh man you just feel that
emotional transference there in that
scene i love that dude absolutely talk
about your time with your fellow
spider-man what did you share off-screen
compare notes about spandex and fans he
goes on to say i think the first time we
were all in the suit together it was
hilarious because it's like just three
ordinary dudes who are just actors just
hanging out but then also you just
become a fan and say oh my god we're all
together in the suits and we're doing
the points
which i mean they must have been doing
that constantly on set
there was talk about going to the
bathroom and you know padding around the
package
i'm glad look at toby mcguire's dude
we talked about what worked for each of
us tom was jealous because i have little
zippers in my suit that i can get my
hands out of very easily to work his
phone he had to use his nose because he
couldn't access his hands we would have
deeper conversations too and talk about
our experiences with the character and
to have amy pascal there who has seen
through nine movies including
spider-verse it was a revelatory
experience for her realizing how much
life and time she'd given to this
character that was beautiful and
profound i'm wondering pascal's actually
getting some love for them for the first
time ever because she always gets the
blame for like yeah things that go wrong
there's a line i improvised in the movie
looking at mcguire and holland and i
tell them
what
yeah i love them that was just me loving
them oh that was one of the best moments
in the movie no way i want to know
[ __ ] i want to know how the rest of that
scene then came together like was that
their initial reaction and then we're
like [ __ ] we got to cover that wherever
we're reading all this is it really
sounds like they let them form their
characters form their relationships
together and then wrote around that
which is all that life is there it's not
just the drama and the hack that's also
the fun and the camaraderie oh that's so
great that's so great hope for cinema
scorsese yeah scorsese it's all a big
dick of you the screenwriters said at
one point they consider bringing back
kirsten dunstan emma stone what would
you have liked to see for your peter and
gwen oh my god i don't even know where
to start with that it's too big gwen had
agency in our film on her final day she
shows up i tried to restrain her from
showing up to that scene with electro
jamie foxx i knew that it was too
dangerous but she chose to be there she
had a hand on her own destiny in that
way and that movie is about fate i will
say the image of catching zendaya's mj
that was really beautiful and it kind of
sold me on the whole thing that is it is
the arc and the redemption absolutely
amazing you gotta know that's gonna
affect people huge a lot of the
conversation about this movie has been
about a sort of redemption for your
spider-man narratively commercially how
does that feel i'm so grateful i'm just
really really grateful that i got to tie
up some loose ends for the peter that i
was playing i love the character and i'm
grateful that i got to work with these
incredible actors this incredible
director and marvel in conjunction with
sony little sony cred uh it was joyful
and a feeling of closure for me there
was so many unanswered questions from my
peter where uh we left it i got to step
back in and got some healing for him and
also really supporting holland's peter
and honoring his character completing
that trilogy not distracting or
detracting from it i really love that
because it seemed like he really knew
his position here that he was here to
support absolutely not to try to steal
the show or try to put to become the
center of attention but to be a support
for this trilogy but also you know gives
some closure to his character and then
of course the the thing that uh yeah
this is the last one uh would you be
open to coming back to the character i
mean yes
definitely open to something if it felt
right peter and spider-man those
characters are all about service to the
greater good and the many he's a
working-class boy from queens that knows
struggle and loss and is deeply
empathetic i would try to borrow peter
parker's ethical framework in that if
there was an opportunity to step back in
and tell more of that story i would have
to feel very sure and certain in myself
hell yeah oh he's totally coming back
he's a thousand percent coming back he's
coming back man you could just feel it
there's some video that i was working on
uh earlier today making some notes about
like all the morbius all the clues that
have venom and morbius from the andrew
garfield spider-man universe i was like
making a bunch of notes for it um we
might do that this weekend this right
here just him talking about it this
extensively and then saying he want to
come back the fans petitioning for him
to come back and the amount of love
adoration you know sony's paying
attention to all that [ __ ] fans want it
he wants it it's happening you know
what's happening
this is a great article this is really
juicy stuff man
this is really fulfilling i was very
happy with this one this is one of the
most exciting most exciting things i've
read what it feels like one of the rare
yeah like press articles you read where
i'm like wow this really is apparent in
the film i can feel your enthusiasm like
yeah it's uh it makes me so happy guys
what did you think about everything
andrew garfield had to say what was your
biggest takeaway for what he said here
put down the comments if you wanted to
return subscribe click that bell hit
that like button we will catch you
mother effort soon
you